[موسيقى]
مساء الخير
عندكم فكره انتم جايين ليه هنا النهارده
والاسف مش انا اللي جايبكم الميتافيرس هي
اللي جايباكم
في 2021 مارك ذكر بيرج مؤسس فيسبوك اتكلم
على
الناس توقعت ان هو ده اوريجينال
لكن لا
في 1992 الكاتب الامريكي مين
عمل نوبل اسمها سنو كراش تخيلوا ايه اللي
حصل في النوبل دي
بطل الروايه كان عامل توصيل بيتزا
كان متخيل في ان هو هيكون محارب ساموراي
ابتداء للنقطه
المختلفه قررت تتبنى فكره
ماين كرافت المشكله
كانت
بتخاطب الجيمرز او الجيمنج فظهر مسكون عند
الناس الميتافيرس هي جيمنج
لكن مش ده الصح
فيها جدا
وممكن اعمل المدارس
في كلاس مصر
للكلام اللي
لو تخيلنا ان دلوقتي فيرس عملت
اقدر اتخيل حركه
المختلفه كانت المعلومه هتوصل لك بشكل
اسرع وبشكل اسهل ودقيق
عمرها ما هتكون بديل العمليه التعليميه او
دور المدرس او المختلفه او الماتيز بتاعه
التعليم لكن هي هتكون نوع من انواع توصيل
المعلومه بشكل احسن وبشكل اسهل ما بين
الطالب والمدرس في الهيلت كير فيلد مثلا
ممكن اعمل
اكثر من مره قبل ما يعمل على المريض
ايفنت بشجع الناس انها تحضر من اي مكان في
العالم وبشجع ما بين الناس
تخيلوا معايا لو الملك توت عنخ امون رجع
الحكم وقرر ان هو يرجع امجاد ورقي الحضاره
المصريه القديمه
ده لدكتور اشرف عبد المحسن استاذ في جامعه
عين شمس قرر يتخيله ويطبقه وعملنا مدينه
ميتاتوت هي اول مدينه مصريه على
الميتافيرس كانت فكرتها اعاده رقيه ومجد
الحضاره المصريه القديمه في الوقت الحالي
انا مش بعمل للحضاره المصريه او السمبلز
بتاعتهم انا بعمل من الحضاره المصريه لو
كانت كملت لحد دلوقتي شكلها هيكون عامل
ازاي
الفكره بتاعه ميتا توت ما كانتش في
البدايه فكره على في الاول اتواز ديزايند
تو بيقفيزيكال سيتي
كان اسمها توت ايرا زي اسم الشركه كانت
مدينه هرميه عرضها كيلو في كيلو في ارتفاع
600 متر فتقدر باربع اضعاف هرم خوفو
نظرا لان هي حجمها الكبير ده فاتوازنات
فيزيبل ان هي تتعمل
لان هي عايزه اكتر من 200 مليار جنيه مصري
فقررنا ان احنا نعملها
في الاول كانت الفكره ان احنا نعملها جيم
بعدين قلنا احنا عايزين حاجه
نعملها على
الموضوع كان بالسهوله دي اكيد لا في الاول
كنا عايزين نعملها اذكيم
هو
ظهرت عندنا مشاكل للاسف ما كناش عارفين
نخلي ان المدينه اكسسبل من الفي ار جلاسس
او من اللابتوبز او من الموبايل كان
الاوبشن التاني ان احنا نخليها هوستد على
بيتيح كويسه لكن في حاليا في الميتافيرس
الحالي مش هو ده شكلها النهائي لكن
نحو بشكلها الاكبر ففي كتيره زي انا مثلا
ما بعرفش اعمل
بشكل كبير
ما بعرفش اخلي في انتر اكشن ما بيني وما
بين الاوبجيكت بشكل كبير
ما يستحملش اكتر من 500 ل 1000 جزر في نفس
الوقت
فيها ناس كثيره جدا في نفس الوقت اخر حاجه
النسبيشل مش بيقدر يخليني احط سبايسي
كبيره جدا
فبضطر ان انا اقسم المدينه لسبيس اصغر
التحكم هيكون التنقل ما بين السبيس
والتاني عن طريق حاجه اسمها
المدينه حاليا هي على
اي وقت عن طريق او اللاب توب او الكمبيوتر
او الموبايل
احنا كنا عايزين نعمل اوانس للابورتينز
الموجوده على
فعملناز مع ناس كثيره جدا
عملناها مثلا عملناها مع هشام خرمه كاول
ايجيبشن كومبوزر على
عملنا مع مكدوب ارت جاليري او كافيتش
واخيرا عملنا مع احمد رافت مذيع الشارع
كاول توك شو في
ترم تاني مهم جدا
زي الميتافيرس
هو
في نقطه ما فهمتهاش بيفسرها لي بشكل احسن
يحطها لي
عامل زي سيرش لكن هو مورس
او ابلكيشن كتيره جدا زي ميه جوني اللي
بيحول
زي بيتهوفن بيحاول
زي سنتيزيا بيحاول
وغيرها جدا
لما ظهرت الابليكيشن دي وبقت
انسب الناس لنصين المؤيد
والمعارض
المؤيد شايف ان الابليكيشن دي ممكن
استخدمها انا حسن
واحسن
لما باجي بطلع اوت بوت مش باخده هو اعمله
انا بقى
عشان اطلع حاجه ثانيه احسن طب والمعارض
المعارض شايف الابليكيشن دي هتقعد الناس
في بيتها
وهتخلي ان شغلي يقل وهيستبدل اماكن او شغل
ناس
لكن هي دي المشكله ان التكنولوجي
ما ينفعش اقول لحد ما تستخدمش التكنولوجي
اكني بقول الرسام ما يستخدمش الفرشه
بتاعته
فالحل الوحيد ان انا دايما اكون قبض اخلي
الناس تستخدم الابلكيشن دي وتكون
لان اللي مش هيعمل ده
يؤسفني انا اقول هي شكرا
[تصفيق]